[Music]
scientists have now unveiled the world's
first living robots last year and they
can reproduce now oh my god that seems
so scary
they are
just go ahead and imagine it for another
second before i say no
no no how do they reproduce so what they
do is uh they cluster free floating stem
cells together
and just for context these bots uh so
it's like biotechnology yeah these
things that were kind of available
that's even scary they're considered
living machines not in that they are
like uh actual like metal robots that we
normally understand they are actual like
stem cells from frogs they're they're
bundles of stem cells from african
clawed frogs aka xenopus lavish or
whatever which is why they're called
xenobots
and then they're programmed to
accomplish specific tasks like via
again i'm not scientists about like
[ __ ] electricity and different things
that they actually do in order to
actually
um
in i guess control the will of these
stem cells wow wow haven't they seen
planet of the apes
or irobot or i
they've been trying to warn us this
isn't crazy [ __ ] but these scientists
want to play with fire
[ __ ] [ __ ] scientists and now and
they're like don't worry don't worry
it's in a secure lab it's not nothing's
gonna happen yeah like covered
so yeah for real dude since the original
study the team has been working to
harness the power of these tiny robots
named xenobots after the clawed frog's
genus
xenopus and in a new development the
team announced that xenobots can now
reproduce in a way that is completely
different from any planet animal known
to science
by scooping up free floating cells and
assembling them into new clusters so
what they pretty much do is like these
little things are on [ __ ] petri
dishes and stuff yeah there's a bunch of
other stem cells that are just there and
then these xenobots will just go around
and start like like pac-man just kind of
scooping and picking up the other things
and then making circles around them to
cluster them together and then when
other xenobots are aware almost like a
hive mentality of like a culture of them
they begin assisting and also taking
other like
themselves clustering together and then
over a period of time using the
clustering uh like just compacting it
and then also interjecting some sort of
other
life juice that's like venom dude they
[ __ ] become venomous the back blacks
and it goes into you and now you're
venom right but the thing could leave
you and then [ __ ] going to you and
your venom that sounds like some wally
[ __ ]
goddamn it says uh frogs have a way of
reproducing that they normally use but
when you
liberate the cells from the rest of the
embryo and you give them a chance to
figure out how to be in a new
environment not only do they figure out
a new way to move but they also figure
out apparently a new way to reproduce
who wants to see a little video i do i
want to see so
are we going to look at a little frog we
are not looking at a frog we are looking
at the stem cells that have been
clustered together in order to create
the xenobots and now the xenobots are
doing their own clustering i hope after
this they [ __ ] exploded that [ __ ] and
completely
destroyed it yeah
destroy all evidence
[Laughter]
wow
so you see how they just [ __ ] go in
circles and they start scooping
are they real robots or are they like oh
my god
[Music]
but it's biotech
wow
[Music]
[Music]
inspirational music so good
inspirational royalty free tracks the
best
all right all right that's insane
so they're doing this [ __ ] at wuhan
to make covet better
so to create xenobox in the first place
the team used a super computer to create
a blueprint for a new life form
that already sounds [ __ ] nuts to me
by the way no i'm good with the design
in hand they collected stem cells from
the frogs embryos and incubated them
before reconfiguring them frankenstein
style using tiny tweezers and an
electrode into the shape designed by the
supercomputer the xenobots could then be
programmed to complete certain tasks and
they've grown more complex since then
in about five days xenobots can form
spheres of around 3000 cells when they
cluster and since they're able to work
together the robo blob can move around
and push single cells together to form
new xenobots
it's a process called kinematic
self-replication a process only observed
in molecules and not living things one
xenobot parent can begin a pile and then
by chance a second parent can push more
cells into that pile and so on
generating the child so to speak god
damn
but there's a limit to how many baby
bots can be created it turns out the
xenobots will replicate once one
generation they will make the children
but the children are too small and weak
to make grandchildren so it can't
continue in the cycle so it's like a
donkey
is that how it works or the meal or mule
uh or a biker yeah
they're i think their children's are
steriles
that's good yeah until they
until there's a big kid
and another big kid
and then they figure it out and then
they figure it out
yeah it's kind of like the survival of
the fittest right evolution so it says
though this research is in its infant
phases the team has high hopes for the
xenobots with further development they
could be used in medicine such as to
help deliver drugs within the body or to
clean up environmental contaminants um
pretty much anything that
you can throw a [ __ ] organism in so
i'm saying so like it's a it's an
organic wall-e dude
we made all this human trash like i bet
you one day they're gonna invent
something that eats and uh plastic
they're gonna find something that comes
and digests plastic and then they're
going to release it but imagine that
being like super sized in the ocean yeah
it would just look like a giant [ __ ]
brain blog slug
and it would just be going around
moseying its way and just eating stuff
and then like you're
like we're gonna just have like
bio computer tech [ __ ] live but
really weird soft squishy weird alien
like a big jellyfish yeah you ever seen
um
starship troopers yeah remember the
[ __ ] brain alien thing i imagine that
giant blob
just sucking out brains some say we are
genetic experiments from aliens
i think we are dude we're weird
so that's why it could happen
my parents are aliens all of us illegal
aliens illegal
it's fine
refugees man
i mean i i i personally think that uh
i these stuff these things can't be
stopped like it's like you watch the
[ __ ] uh irobots and the different
movies talk about skynet obviously
technology is going to like overtake us
all about
it's gonna happen anyway so next
progression it's okay it's evolution
we're gonna die anyway we're all gonna
die after after you reading the article
and explaining a little bit i still
don't know what half that [ __ ] means but
it does make me feel a little bit safer
yeah but they're gonna be done more to
understand you know just the everything
no but the fact that you're gonna that
you're gonna use this for medicine and
all that type of stuff i'm like okay
cool and that's how it starts right
that's how it always starts anybody
watch the new arcadian show arcane on
netflix i heard it's very good
what's that about
uh without any spoilers because based
off of league of legends champions and
stuff like that let's just say the whole
point why i'm even bringing it up it's
like a weapon tech when you first like
develop the tech it's like to to do good
or good yeah it's like to protect this
or to make this a work chain faster or
like to like save innocent civilians
from having to do this labor until the
president of pfizer gets a hold of it
exactly and then and then suddenly
becomes weaponized right so like it's i
feel like we're at this weird point
where um it's not it's not so like
physical realm 3d inventions we're not
reinventing the wheel or creating like a
steam engine or whatever we're like now
into this new space of like biotech and
other things that we can't [ __ ]
fathom in our minds but the second we
weaponize [ __ ] like that yeah
dangerous like covey yeah i like
covering understand something like this
is uh you know our insulin it's made by
bacteria yeah so they program the
bacteria to only produce insulin
so it's almost like you know when you
have a tumor it's an uncontrolled growth
right it's like your dna or your rna
whatever it there's like a glitch in the
system so instead of constantly
repeating a sequence and creating the
different proteins your body needs it's
just i'm only making this protein so now
you have this uncontrolled growth that
turns into a tumor it's kind of that
concept in a bacteria and it's only
making insulin and that's how we harvest
that and we harvest that insulin for our
program a bacteria through the rna dude
you get some of those through the rna
you program it and then uh because
everything that is that you see like
your eye color [ __ ] hair color
whatever it's all a genetic code so if
you figure out the code then you can
make it produce what you want to produce
yeah and that's how insulin is made and
so i'm sure they're adjusting whatever
the code they need to get this uh robot
to do only one function
until the president of pfizer gets a
hold of it and there's going to be doing
some questions damn visor i feel i feel
like there's like a lot of really
good applications for this technology um
but i think something interesting is
that like when the scientists who make
this stuff do you think they think about
like all the really bad outcomes that
could happen [ __ ] me talking about the
nobel prize they're about to win because
like because i know that um in their
most recent um [ __ ] geeks dude were
they uh interviewed the guy who created
deep fakes or something and then they're
saying like yeah this is a really cool
technology but now i feel that's just
been used to do porn
exclusively almost exclusively these are
gonna make fleshlights only
the best rubber
i feel like these dudes are so smart
they like always underestimate how
[ __ ] dumb the rest of the world is so
then when it gets used for other [ __ ]
they're like what the [ __ ]
i gave you a gift to cure cancer and you
guys are just jacking off all day yeah
with deep fakes
[Music]
you